which of the following triangles are
similar to triangle ABC so let's just
review what similarity means when we're
talking about triangles so let's say
this is one triangle and I'll assume
it's a right triangle although what I'm
about to say is true for any triangle
and let's say this is another one you
have similar triangles if all of the
corresponding angles are equivalent so
that angle is equivalent to that angle
and I drew that as a right angle let's
say that this angle is equivalent to
this angle and let's say that this angle
is equivalent to that angle then these
two triangles are similar they are not
necessarily congruent they don't
necessarily have all of the same sides
but when you have they do have all of
the same angles when you have all of the
same angles the ratios between
corresponding sides is going to be
constant so for example if this side has
length 2 and this side has length 1 you
have a two to one ratio between the
second longest side and the shortest
side then you're also going to have a
two to one ratio here so maybe this has
length 3 then this one would be one
point five three to one point five is
the same thing as two to one now let's
think about the triangles that they are
proposing so the first one is triangle
triangle CDE so C C D C de just like
triangle a b c this is going to be a
right triangle this is going to be a
right triangle how do I know well side
CB is perfectly horizontal inside a B is
perfectly vertical same thing side de is
perfectly horizontal inside C E is
perfectly vertical now you might realize
that you have the same line acting as a
hypotenuse of both of these both of
these triangles so you have the same
line right over here and if we wanted to
prove that the corresponding angles are
equivalent we just have to break out a
little bit of our geometry we see that
we have these two vertical lines so see
this line segment C e you could view it
as part of a larger line that goes like
this it is parallel to a B it is
parallel to a B so if you view these as
two parallel lines so that is parallel
to this then and you have a transversal
right over here then corresponding
angles are going to be equivalent so
this angle right over here is going to
be equivalent to that angle right over
there
similarly similarly I have trouble
saying that word segment de segment de
right over here is parallel to BC and so
if you once again look at the blue line
as a transversal this angle is going to
be equivalent to that angle so all of
their corresponding angles are
equivalent so these are definitely
similar triangles now I went through
that fairly long winded geometry way of
thinking about it but there's an easier
way to think about it anytime you have a
line and you construct a right angle
that it where essentially the bit of
right triangle where the base of the
right triangle is essentially your
change in X between these two points so
if you think about going from Point C to
point A and if you first just wanted to
have a change in X so this is our change
in X right over there and then you have
a change in Y and then you have a change
in Y so this is our change in Y you're
going to construct a right triangle and
the ratio between these two sides is
always going to be the same so Delta Y
the change in Y this triangle this is
the Greek letter Delta just a shorthand
for saying change in Y which is the
length of this side over your change in
X is always going to be constant when
you're dealing when you are dealing with
a line so any triangle that's
constructed this way from this line the
ratio between the corresponding sides
are going to be equivalent and they're
going to be similar triangles so that
would have been an easier way to think
about this right over here now let's
look at the other options that give us D
F G D F G so that's D F G well there's
not really a lot that we can say about D
F G we're not really using the line
anymore as a hypotenuse so we're not
going to throw that
in there as being similar I could we
could actually look at the lengths and
all of that if we wanted but we'd see
that it's not similar C D G C D G well
once again this is not let me see D G
clean this up a little bit C D G I'll do
in I'll do in let's see I've already
used all you do in blue so C D G this is
not a right triangle we're not this
isn't just a change in X right over here
this isn't a horizontal line and this
one right over here is not a vertical
line so once again this is not similar
in fact this is not even a right
triangle so we'll mark these both of
these out and then they say ADF so a DF
well once again a DF it's a right
triangle it's a right triangle between D
and F you're essentially it's your
change in X going from D so D is that D
is at negative 2 a is at 3 this right
over here is your change in X you
literally had to go 5 this length right
over here is 5 and then this right over
here is now vertical line this is a
right triangle this is your change in Y
so that is your change in Y and these
two ratios are always going to be
constant when your hypotenuse is a line
so once again this is just one of those
classic right triangles constructed from
the line where the base is the change in
X this height is a change in Y the
hypotenuse is the line itself these are
going to be similar so this is
definitely a similar triangle and now
let's actually input it just to make
sure that we got the right answer so I'm
saying that and that are right triangles
or sorry that they're similar triangles
to triangle ABC